did i ever tell you about how sal dreamt
about gary's dead brother
no gary okay so i'm going
i'm going completely off of memory but
but the thing is that my brother came to
sal in a dream
he's using cell as a conduit to tell me
that everything's okay
you know sal's off his [ __ ] rocker
imagine your brother
now is in heaven i assume and
he's got to get in touch with you who
does he choose he went to sow
prevail it to a guy who can't say
prevalent
[Music]
i'll tell you exactly what happened at
gary and i we were at a cocktail party
in a mansion and gary and i were sipping
champagne we were in tuxedos
and above there was a staircase that
went up to a balcony
and at the center of the balcony was
gary's brother
and i said gary your brother is here and
gary said no he's not my brother's dead
and then the the dream switched to a
scene where i was standing on the
balcony with his brother
and he said sal i'm here to let you know
that my brother does great things for me
and i appreciate it
but he doesn't believe that i still
exist you need to let him know that i'm
still alive
and i'm still looking over him i gotta
take a breath
because i i don't even know where to
begin on this [ __ ] dream you
understand that a dream
is all of your [ __ ] you didn't meet
gary's brother
do you understand that i hate to tell
you this howard but i did
okay and he needed to get this message
out to gary your intense desire
to get in the on the good side of gary
created this dream you understand
so it's twofold my intense desire to get
on the good side of gary which is
important
and secondly for gary to open his eyes
and ears to realize that his brother
is alive and he's around him you had a
dream
and conjured up gary's brother for
psychological reasons i'm not going to
go into right now
and then in a moment of ridiculousness
you brought this to gary it upset you
gary didn't it
i'm going to be very honest it weirded
me out like i didn't understand
it seemed like sal's intentions were
good
but i don't fully understand it i will
tell you the dream's not over
and then so of course like all of this
sounds like sweet and from a movie and
harps and angels and everybody
and then what happened sal well then it
took a left turn i didn't really want to
discuss it but
unfortunately to be honest with the
dream on the way out there was an orgy
going on in the garage
and there was a lady sitting on a urinal
with her back up against the urinal and
she was masturbating and
shooting pee out and there was this
monstrous orgy going on
my jaw dropped and i was like holy [ __ ]
this is amazing like
and you understand that you like that
and then you can't forget yeah you
conjured that up in a dream
and i kind of regret even bringing that
part up because i think it it kind of
dilutes
the importance of gary's brothers it's
kind of negative
it negates the first part because it
just seems like these are just wacky
things swirling around in your head
it's unbelievable unbelievable
sal wants to be special in the worst way
he wants something he wants some sort of
connection with people that he can't get
well he has no connections here on earth
sorry he's not looking to the
other world you're so sweet robin
nobody's coming for you and my dream job
and that's for sure
they're like vodka
you